[Music]
today i'm canceling ugly people um now
stick with me i'm not attacking those of
us who are aesthetically deficient
through no fault or choice of our own
we're safe
what i'm canceling instead is
intentional ugliness
and not just as it applies to human
beings personally but also to the works
of human beings our art our our
architecture our music
there's ugliness everywhere
the world has become a very ugly place
now it retains its natural beauty you
can still go to san francisco and if you
step over the human feces and the meth
addicts laying all over the sidewalk and
if you can wade through the mob of
hoodlums looting the gucci outlet you
can look out at the ocean and it's just
as beautiful as it always has been
there's beauty in the world wherever
we've allowed it to remain but those
places are fewer and farther between as
there's been a campaign to uglify
everything including ourselves
as for the uglification of people tiktok
provides an extensive catalog of such
cases here's one highlighted by libs of
tick tock in the video one female user
shows pictures of herself from some
years ago when she was a normal decent
looking young woman
but but that has changed let's watch
this
[Music]
okay well if you couldn't see there
because you're listening to the audio
podcast she chopped her hair off she put
on weight
and she stuck piercings all over her
face
her feminine appearance is gone in favor
of this androgynous mutilated look i
feel comfortable commenting on the
transformation because she's apparently
quite proud of it proud enough to
advertise it on social media
she is certainly uglier now much uglier
and that's how she intends it
many such cases you find this trend even
among pop stars who used to be
criticized for being unreasonably
beautiful
more and more they freed themselves from
the shackles of physical beauty and
embraced something else entirely i saw
an interview with demi lovato recently
where she was talking about getting in
touch with aliens through meditation
and somehow that wasn't the weirdest
part of the interview the weirdest part
was her appearance she was sporting a
mullet
and a baggy button-down that looked like
something that she grabbed out of her
dad's hamper
again this is this is part of a larger
trend even the female celebrities who
remain beautiful don't want you to
notice it
supermodel emily ratajkowski was has
just released a book of essays
though you'd probably want to read an
essay by a supermodel about as much as
you want to see me posing for modeling
shots where she complains about the as
the new york times puts it the
oppression of the male gaze
she has built a career on being
attractive in front of the camera she's
made millions off of the male gaze and
yet she hates it it oppresses her she
wishes she could climb into a cave and
model for no one and still get paid
millions
but there isn't much of a market for
cave modeling so she sticks with the
regular kind and whines about it
the attack on beauty also includes an
attack on those who notice or appreciate
beauty
yet ratajkowski's complaints aren't as
absurd as the rise of plus-sized
modeling where morbidly obese women don
skimpy clothing to show off their excess
baggage we're not meant to appreciate
their beauty i mean morbid obesity is
not beautiful since it's
self-destructive and deadly so much as
we're supposed to admire the physical
ugliness on principle well here's the
holiday gift you've got to buy someone
this year kamikoto knives kamikoto taps
into more than 800 years of traditional
technique from honshu japan each
kamikoto knife goes through a rigorous
19-step process that takes several years
from start to finish to complete because
of their single bevel edge kamikoto
knives can achieve an unbelievably sharp
edge that you just can't get with other
knives they can cut through your rib eye
like butter they can cut through look at
this
see well that's how that's how
why is this there uh that's how sharp
these things are chemical knives are
used by several chefs working at
michelin star restaurants so click the
link below or go to camikoto.com matt
walsh and use promo code matt walsh to
save an extra fifty dollars today a few
years ago calvin klein unveiled massive
billboards in interior in times square
with fat people posing in their
underwear
this is not beauty but a kind of
anti-beauty now as i said this extends
far beyond the physical appearance of
human beings when it comes to pop stars
as they grow increasingly uglier and
more weird and brutal in appearance so
does their music
think about think about this
how often do you do you hear a pop song
even one you like
and think wow this is beautiful
now you might like a song because it's
catchy or it sounds cool or whatever but
not usually because it's beautiful
there was a time most of human history
in fact when the statement i like this
music was synonymous with the statement
this music is beautiful the idea of
liking music for any other reason and
beauty would have seemed absurd it still
is actually
most music today even if it's catchy is
also nonetheless obnoxious and vulgar
and stupid and unpleasant
the same can be said about many of the
cars we drive while we listen to the
music and the buildings that we're
driving to
almost all buildings are ugly nowadays
we've gotten so used to it we don't even
notice it
but take note of it next time you're
driving anywhere
i mean the buildings are hideous almost
all of them
it only becomes noticeable when the
ugliness is directly supplanting
something beautiful that came before it
the notre dame cathedral in paris burned
and now they're going to replace it with
a contemporary monstrosity replete with
obnoxious light displays and modern art
and other forms of gaudiness
speaking of art modern art is defined by
its ugliness
it is like the tiktok user ugly on
purpose
to make a point of some kind
but what is the point
i mean why is everything and everybody
so ugly
why is the modern aesthetic so harsh and
ghastly and strange i think there are a
few things happening here let's talk
about two of them one
modern society revolts against standards
we celebrate ambiguity because we
imagine that there's freedom to be found
in that vague sort of fog
we seek to escape expectation
a woman rejects the standards of
femininity with its coherence and its
clear lines and calls herself non-binary
but a beautiful woman by definition is
one who best exemplifies those feminine
traits
a woman is most beautiful when she most
looks like a woman
that's one of the reasons why morbid
obesity is not beautiful on a woman or
on anybody
it's not beautiful on a woman because it
it
not only is it is it deadly and lethal
and unhealthy and self-destruct but it
also it also detracts from it literally
covers up
the feminine traits that make a woman
beautiful
just as the modern artist seeks to
escape standards and expectations by
painting random splotches on a page and
calling it a tree or whatever
but a beautiful painting of a tree is
one that most captures the essence of a
tree
the splotches are nothing in particular
so they can't be beautiful
two modern society is preoccupied by
convenience and utility we don't strive
for transcendence we don't recognize
that anything like transcendence can
exist we reject it as a category and so
we build giant gray depressing
nondescript buildings and we fill our
cities with them our ancestors built
palaces and cathedrals
i mean they were literally reaching up
towards the sky towards something
greater that's why they built those
buildings
we build really big shoe boxes
we live in the shoe boxes we work in
them we go to church in them
the designs are practical and cheap
they're useful
but they're not beautiful
beauty reaches for something beyond
beauty cares about truth
our culture
just
doesn't just fail to seek truth it hates
it
and it produces art and music and
architecture and people who reflect that
preference
so everything is ugly and ugly on
purpose
not on accident like me
and that is why purposeful ugliness
today is finally canceled if you enjoyed
this video be sure to give it a thumbs
up and share it with all your friends